So, hi, and welcome to our webcast,
MBA Student Insights LGBT at the GSB.
My name's Marco, and I'm a second
year MBA student here at the GSB,
and we'll be talking about the LGBT
student experience here on campus and
try to answer as many questions as we can.
To submit a question to us about
what it's like to be a student here,
just click the Chat button at the top
of your screen, enter your question,
and click Send to All Panelists.
So click the Chat button at the top,
enter your question, and
enter Send to All Panelists.
We're not going to be talking about
the admissions process, the application,
or financial aid, but there are staff
from the MBA Admissions Office that
are going to answer those types of
questions directly in the chat box itself.
All right, so first things first,
we're going to start off with some intros.
I have Wynn, and Marcella here.
Why don't you start by telling us
a bit about where you're from,
what you did before coming to the GSB,
and what your goals are after graduation.
>> Awesome, I guess I'll kick us off.
My name is Wynn Chessen.
I'm so excited to be on this panel.
I grew up in Chapel Hill, North Carolina.
That's where I came out.
I went to the University of North Carolina
at Chapel Hill for undergrad.
Studied womens studies,
gender studies, and sexuality studies.
And then I went to work
in New York City for
an LGBT rights non-profit
called Immigration Equality.
So, all my professional
experience prior to
the GSB was actually focused
on championing LGBT equality,
especially for immigrant
communities in the United States.
And I'm a career-switcher so
I'm not exactly sure what's next for me,
but I'm really excited to be at the GSB,
to have so many amazing new opportunities.
And so, ask me in a year where I am.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Marcella.
>> Hello everyone,
also very excited to be here.
My name is Marcella.
I am from Mexico.
I went to Monterey Tech where I studied
industrial engineering,
then had a more traditional background
doing management consulting for two years.
But I'm now, after the GSB,
going to go work at The Nature Conservancy
which is an environmental nonprofit,
and I'm very excited about that.
Also glad to be here today.
>> Perfect, thanks Marcella.
So as for myself, like I said,
my name's Marco Chan.
I'm a second year here at the GSB, but
coincidentally just like Wynn I'm a dual
degree student in public administration
at the Kennedy School as well.
In terms of before school,
I studied romance studies.
Or actually, I'm from Canada,
so you have NAFTA up here.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I also lived for a while in Macau.
In terms of educational background,
I studied romance studies at Harvard.
And then worked at Bain & Company in
consulting for a couple of years.
And was at the World Bank for
a bit in International development.
And then long-term, I'm considering
either LGBT advocacy full-time,
or I'm also really interested
in Canadian politics and policy.
So,
>> Awesome.
>> Very dissimilar things.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right, well, so with that,
why don't we just get started with some
questions that the audience has submitted.
So, why don't we start with the first one,
what is the LGBT community
like at the GSB?
>> Do you want me to start?
>> Yeah.
>> So,
I should start by saying I love the GSB.
And, one of the most
important communities for
me since I've gotten
here has been GSB pride,
and that's kind of the all-inclusive
MBA one, MBA two and MBA three.
>> [LAUGH]
>> MSX.
>> Yeah.
>> PhD.
>> One year students, PhD students.
And, I think it's because
they host a retreat
very soon after you get onto campus.
So as you're kind of establishing yourself
and trying to make friends with section
mates, it's kind of nice to break away
from that from a minute and get to meet,
not just people of your year outside
of your section, but also get to meet,
start friendships that are MBA twos, or.
I met both of you at that retreat,
and that was just really meaningful.
So that's kind of how it started for me.
>> Yeah.
>> Cool.
>> I really wanted to let Wynn go first,
because as he mentioned, I'm an MBA three.
The program is usually two
years as I'm sure you know, but
I joined the Greek candidate with
the School of Earth, Energy, and
Environmental Studies, so E-IPER.
So I wanted to provide
the historic perspective.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And it seemed really exciting
to see how the GSB pride
community has changed.
There were fewer applause when I started,
and it was a more,
in a way a more homogeneous community.
And I'm really excited to see, and
I hope you'll talk about prom
where you got to wear a dragon.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I just,
[LAUGH] Feel like the conversations and
the experience here being so
much more inclusive and stronger.
And again, coming back to the fact that
I'm an MBA three, it's really exciting
to make friends with the first years
even now after my friends graduated.
And then with the second years.
And GSB Pride has really
been at the core of that.
>> Yeah, I think as for
my thoughts on what the LGBT
community's been like here,
I'll offer two things.
I think the first is that for
me, partly because my social and
professional interest is in the LGBT
community, it always feels like home base.
So it's nice that we have a group
where it's big enough that,
to your points there's quite a bit
of diversity in our group in terms
of work background,
where people grew up, ideologies even.
There's enough of that, but it's also a
tight-knit enough group where I feel like
I really do know every single
person to one degree or another.
So it's nice to have,
we get together every Thursday for
drinks in different people's houses,
we have events all the time, we'll go
together to different Pan Stanford or
local San Francisco LGBT events.
So, it's nice to have that community.
And then I think the second
thing I'll share is that,
again, to what Marcella said,
I think frankly,
everyone's kind of surprised by how
international our LGBT experience is.
We have people from China,
India, Saudi Arabia, Canada,
Mexico,
>> [LAUGH]
>> Brazil.
So I think it's really enriched
discussions that we've had,
particularly with allies, around what it
means for us to think about inclusion and
diversity in our own personal lives,
but also in the workplace.
So all these different places that people
from the GSB will ultimately end up
back at.
So, that's a piece I'll share around that.
The second question that we have is,
how did you know it was the right time for
you to get an MBA?
Why wasn't that five years ago?
Why wasn't that two years later?
>> I thought again,
being in management consulting,
I thought that I was under a deadline
to apply before my two years were up.
It turned out maybe that wasn't
quite what I thought it was.
But I just thought I had
to do it at that point.
The right time is probably when
you feel it's the right time.
I'm super glad I got to do it then,
because the GSB has really allowed me to
leverage what I had learned in consulting,
but really transition to a career
that's very meaningful to me.
So, in a way,
I want to say the sooner the better,
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] But whenever it's right for
you.
>> For me it was, if you kind of rewinded
back seven years and asked me would I
be getting an MBA, I think my
answer would've been absolutely no.
But the more I worked in
the LGBT rights world,
the more value I saw as kind of
the organization I was working for
partnered more and
more with Fortune 500 companies.
And When I kind of decided
to come back to school,
it was after an enormous victory for
our community.
And I think the United States Supreme
Court issued the Windsor decision,
and one of the three things
Immigration Equality was working on was
being able to apply for a green card for
your same sex husband or wife.
And so, once we won that key victory,
obviously there's a lot more to do.
But it was this turning point
moment where I got to reassess and
kind of figure out what
do I want to do next.
So for me, it was kind of marked by that
milestone and I always loved school so
the idea of doing something that
could both help me gain new skills,
new knowledge at a moment of uncertainty.
So kind of,
seemed like too good to be true.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I remember, I visited Stanford.
And I had this feeling like I just
stepped on to the GSB campus.
I don't know if you all felt this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But I loved it immediately.
Like, everything was beautiful,
but there was this town square and
people were waving across.
>> Yeah, I-
>> The Quad, and it was just,
it seemed really like a cozy community,
and so I think that,
that also kind of accelerated the,
okay, this is where I want to be now.
>> Nice.
Mine's brief.
Basically, Ditto Marcello.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'll say in particular it just
felt like the right time after
a couple of years of my previous work
to just do some soul searching about
future directions and my values.
So, keep it there.
The third question that we have is,
I like this one,
how did you know the GSB was
the right school for you?
I think we touched on
the that a little bit.
There's a magic moment, but.
>> I met people when I was considering
a applying to the MBA program,
and I met people who have
been to different schools.
I just found myself being more attracted
to the way that GSBers express themselves.
And I remember in one of my essays I
wrote that what I like about Stanford
is that people talked about dreams and
not just goals.
So it just there was like this aura of
excitement and following your passion, and
trying to do something good for
the world and not just yourself.
And that just, yeah,
I was very attracted to that.
>> I mean, when I visited,
it was just a feeling that I had.
I think that, that was maybe a piece
of it but I couldn't quite identify it.
I don't know,
it's hard to answer that specifically.
>> For me, it sounds funny, but
it was actually going to one of
the presentations that the GSB admissions
officers does around the cities.
So I was working in Atlanta at the time,
and I went to the presentation there.
And what struck me about what she said,
and
what the alumni who came into
the presentation were like.
Was that,
this is a place where we think about,
where people are empowered to think about.
I think how success is
different from meaning, and
that by pursuing meaning,
at some point you'll find success.
At some point, you'll be able to sustain
yourself and your material needs.
And so worry about your passion, worry
about your spirit, and worry about your,
like hone in on those values,
and that's what's important.
And I think getting the option
of my soul searching
presented to me that way was just so
compelling.
And I was like, I'm kind of done
with achieving for achieving.
I'm done with ticking boxes, I really do
want to go to this place where the peers,
the structure, the institutions,
the courses are going to push me to do
what is truly important and meaningful.
So, once I saw that butterfly cocoon
slide on the presentation, I was like,
yes, that's right.
All right.
More questions.
This is fun.
How receptive are employers
to LGBT students?
Do they host events?
Are there career panels
that are LGBT oriented?
>> So, as a career switcher.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, in my old job in LGBT rights,
like diversity and that context was
the straight people that worked for us.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But I was really, I feel like as
I'm pivoting to much more traditional
things at least for the summer.
I felt like it was an incredible advantage
to have the LGBT targeted networking.
Like, all of the consulting firms, a lot
of the banks, did targeted dinners or
receptions on campus or in nearby,
for specifically for LGBT students.
So I feel like, kind of,
it's a way to get a little to have like an
internal champion at any of the companies.
Especially, if you're going to a more
traditional pathway for the summer.
>> Yeah.
>> I felt like it was a total advantage.
>> I guess we both worked in industries
before where we were on the other
side of this.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> But, yes, from the other side of that.
I can tell that it really helps
when you attend these events, and
the access that you get to people who
are working there and partners and so on.
So it's really,
it can really make a difference for
going into traditional careers.
>> Even just reaching out to
alums that if you know the company that
you're interested in for the summer,
you have like one additional
filter that you can try on.
And I found that, I mean GSB alumni
have so responsive, but the LGBT
alumni have like gone above and beyond
every time that, like 100% of the time.
>> Yeah, that's a great point and
absolutely true.
As I was doing this job search,
I completely relied on LGBT alumni for
contacts and so on, so great ones.
>> Yeah, I think I will just add that
reaching out MBA is another great
resource for folks that are kind of,
at this life stage and
looking at different business paths.
So it's an organization
that serves MBAs and
perspective MBAs who are LGBTQ identified.
So, there's a conference every year,
we went, it was tons of fun,
I think it's in Dallas this year.
It's also a great chance for
us to connect with both LGBT employers and
other LGBT MBAs and prospective MBAs from
across the country, well, North America.
All right,
we'll do the next question then.
Do any of the classes address LGBT issues?
I can jump into this one,
because I am actually working on
an extension that came out
of LGBT content in a class.
So, I took a class here on, it was
called advanced topics in philanthropy.
And as a part of that, I wasn't
presented with a particular case or
something that was LGBT focused.
But as with most classes here,
I had a lot of latitude in deciding what
my assignments were going to be on, and
how I was going to focus my own lens,
and my own experience in the class.
So I ended up writing a longer
paper about LGBTQ philanthropy.
Which then the professor went and
said, this is super interesting,
it's very contemporary, and
I'd like to actually extend this and
turn it into teaching material.
So, I think the class at some future
point will actually have that
as something to teach with.
But that's one way that I infuse,
by myself, LGBT content in class, and
professors are, as long as you're working
with something you're excited about,
professors are super happy
to let you do what you want.
>> Yeah, I'm not aware of any like
explicitly LGBT classes at the GSB,
but I know that you can take
classes anywhere at the university.
And there are LGBT themed classes outside
of the GSB that we're allowed to take.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, but I'm not aware of any.
>> There is, I'm in the class right now,
Jamie would smack me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
I am in another course right now
called reputation management.
And actually as a part of that,
very recently we've had two
back-to-back LGBT speakers come in.
So one was, Raymond Bron who is
a Stanford undergrad, graduate.
Who came in and talked about his online
activism on LGBT rights with YouTube.
And then a second speaker who came in and
talked to us about how you
manage your reputation at
the frontier of the movement,
she was a GSB alum who played a huge role
in the repeal of Don't Ask, Don't Tell.
And so she actually walked us through
that experience and related it back
to the class, so I actually have
had some LGBT specific curriculum.
And then, the next question.
So how does being an LGBT student at
the GSB relate to your next career move?
And another way of putting it,
how important is it to be openly LGBT and
being in an organization that's going to
support that part of your identity?
>> Yeah, that's really a good one.
I think for the first part,
as we said, for traditional careers,
there will be events, and
you can always reach out to alumni.
But in terms of how it's important
to be in an organization that
will support it, I think just personally,
I couldn't bear any
longer to work at an organization
where I had to be in the closet.
It's just there's so much energy that
you have to pour into hiding things and
making things up, and it deters the type
of relationships that you've had.
So again, I didn't go into this
job through an LGBT channel,
but I definitely made sure that I,
honest and
open from the beginning about my
sexual orientation and my identity.
And I think in the end, that's a little
bit of a personal decision for each one.
A little bit, hopefully, a decision to
try to be a little bit activist and
help the next person.
But yeah, I mean, there's so much research
saying that you have to be authentic.
And that's also something that
the GSB places a lot of emphasis on,
just authenticity and how that helps
build your leadership style and
bring others to support you,
so that's my take.
>> Anything you want to add to that?
>> I mean, I really agree with.
For me,
it would be a jawbreaker if I thought that
the employer didn't support LGBT.
I almost would that say for me,
they'd have to have 100 on the HRC index
that measures how well companies do.
But for me, I'm going to
Goldman Sachs this summer, and
I recruited through
the traditional channels but
I feel like part of what was successful
there was I also used the LGBT network
to get the inside scoop of I see the HRC
score, but what's it really like?
And then also knowing about how they
had partnered on the LGBT stuff I had
done before school really gave me the
confidence to believe on the score that
they had.
But I can't imagine, for
me, being able to do it,
because all of my relevant
experience is really gay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's your resume.
>> Yeah.
So I'm automatically
outed based on what I do.
I think that there are companies where
that would not be that helpful or
regions of the world where it might
be much harder for me to work.
But for me,
I'm willing to make that sacrifice.
>> And I, if you'll let me add,
I'll even add that what you just said,
you wouldn't even consider working
in a place that wasn't accepting of
your identity, that's a great privilege.
And coming from a country that's a little
bit more conservative in some places
around that, it strikes me as something
that's really a privilege, and
in part, something that can
come out of your experience.
>> Yeah, and in fact, we had an event
with allies yesterday where we,
it was just basically a workshop where we
had dialogue between LGBTQ students and
allies at the GSB talking about what
have your experiences been like on
the ally side and on the LGBT side
in the workplace, in particular?
And one ally mentioned
her struggle around.
She worked in a very conservative and
traditional industry where
someone who was LGBTQ identified
really stood out by his or her or
your actions, and so she struggled to
say like, what is my place in that?
And so that, for
me, really underscored different people
are going to have different priorities and
trade offs and where they are in
their own coming out journey.
So I don't want to minimize that either,
it's something that.
I think we've talked about, but want to
really make sure it comes through in
the conversation that it is
very individual and contextual.
>> And it's something that we've talked
a lot about casually over drinks.
Marco mentions that
oftentimes on Thursdays.
A lot of the LGBT students
will get together, and
there's a couple of our classmates that
want to work in the Middle East or that
are going back to home countries where
it's not quite as safe to be openly LGBT.
And how do you navigate that,
how do we support one another?
Talking about,
should I come out to my supervisor or
my supervisor's supervisor,
however that works?
So it's a tricky question, but
it's one that I think that
people are really actively.
Yeah, we want to support one another.
>> 100%.
So thinking about the next question,
how big is the LGBT community at the GSB?
How big is it on the campus at large, and
what kind of support, or involvement,
or interaction does the rest of our
class have with the LGBT community here?
>> Again, I'll provide the story,
the perspective.
It's another part of what's been so
amazing.
I think I've seen it doubled
from my class to your class.
>> Wow.
>> And then, I don't know how it was for
your class seems even larger and
definitely louder [LAUGH].
But yeah, so there's a group, as you said.
I don't know the exact numbers.
I don't know.
>> Yeah, so it's a little tricky,
because obviously,
it's something that is self-identified.
People self-identify or
don't in different contexts.
But what we did report out and
is available through
reaching out is that I think we're
about 5% of most of the classes.
Which I think if I remember, the list was
actually pretty high up in terms of, so.
>> And then, I'm glad there was also
a question about other campus at large,
because I've enjoyed GradQ so much.
GradQ is the LGBT student association for
all graduate schools, so
that includes Stanford law school,
med school, and all the other PhD and
advanced degrees programs.
And I've met so
many interesting people there.
I feel sometimes, my fellow GSB student
get this great opportunity to meet so
many diverse people from
the social psychology department,
law students, everything.
I just really appreciate that
>> Yeah, that's true.
And then, actually, coincidentally,
tomorrow night, we are having, every once
in a while, all the LGBT folk in the area
take over a straight bar in Palo Alto.
So that's actually tomorrow night, and
it's such a pretty sizable community at
the GSB throughout Standford and
in the immediate South Bay Peninsula area.
And then of course,
I used to live in San Francisco myself, so
I go up to the city fairly often to
see friends that are there, and so
there's obviously that community as well.
And then to the second part of that
question, what kind of support or
involvement does the rest
of the class have with us?
I think we've alluded to this a little
bit with some of the ally events, but
anything else you'd want to add to that?
>> I would just say, for me,
it was so striking how different
it was to step back into
a university environment and
have had so much change,
like from when I came out.
So, when I went to university where I
think it was a much more kind of hostile
experience.
I mean there was supportive pockets but
I don't know that it was as welcoming
as I've felt welcomed here,
and I think about, so every,
once a week there are two people from your
class that will give what's called a talk
and they give a lot of their life story,
and you know, obviously every so
often one of those people is LGBT.
And I feel like the conversations that get
sparked through that institution of talk.
Which is one of my favorite things about
Stanford, have been really moving for me.
And then, also just the way that I think
about the support that I have just
from my section and
how they've welcomed and my boyfriend, so
we call all of our partners SOs here, and
I feel like he's been welcomed in so
warmly by all students.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> He's lovely.
>> It's amazing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Thanks.
>> I think so too.
>> But I think that really
says a lot that like, there
are straight people in particular reach
out to him before they reach out to me and
I love that just because I feel like it's
kind of a sign of how things are really
changing and that feels really different
from when I was an undergraduate.
>> Yeah, I think
>> I'll just add that it's not,
the GSP is really diversed, right?
And we mean that in all kinds of ways.
So I don't want to paint over
the fact that there are people here,
with different political points of view
with different ideological leanings.
But I think one thing
that's been super positive
>> About the GSB is that kind of
authenticity, and the inquisitive culture
that we have, because I have had lots
of heart to hearts, and [INAUDIBLE]
conversations
with people where we have disagreed.
So, I think the best example would
be a classmate of mine and a friend.
>> Posted something on Facebook
following the Supreme Court announcement
of same sex marriage in
the United States where he disagreed.
And we ended up having a very frank
two hour lunch about what that meant,
how that landed on me,
how his statement made me feel and
we walked away actually finding more and
more common ground than I expected and
we're still close friends and
I still play with his kids.
So I appreciate those kinds of exchanges
because I recognize that the disagreements
and shifting polar cool winds will always
be in some way a part of our future, so
I appreciate having the community
here to have that really open,
candid dialogue, if anything.
So moving on to the next question.
Is GSB pride purely social or do we take
on advocacy work or do other activities?
>> I want that.
>> You guys are
>> [LAUGH]
>> We were kind of talking about
that before the studio session
started because we were thinking about
>> There's a lot of things a pride
group could do.
We could do education around topics
around HB2 and what that means for
business or you know panels about for
straights allies.
We could do networking stuff for
helping each other get jobs.
We could do social stuff which we do a lot
of and the other thing I think we do a lot
of is If you think of people,
for some of our classmates
this is the first time where it's really
been safe for people to come out and so
thinking back to like when I came out how
important having a supportive community
but also like other support resources,
I think that's one thing that pride does.
It's not exactly social, but providing
all kinds of support for coming out, and
like, what does that mean for
the workplace,
what does that mean in your social life,
with your family.
And then also advocacy around events like
HB2 which he haven't done as much of,
but yeah and
then I would kind of call all the events
you're doing with allies kind of
advocacy slash education and another
one of the things I'm really excited to
see in recent years, the way you do that.
It used to be more of a social club, it's
evolved and I've seen it every year and
with other clubs.
Always kind of evolving to the needs and
what people are excited about.
>> Yeah I'd say it's fairly dependent
on the group of people that
want to take action.
I think with most clubs here,
they're fairly open.
You'll find that all
the clubs have ten leaders,
because everyone wants to be a leader.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But I think that works out in a way
where you share work and people really
take their own personal initiative.
And so I think for example,
when our year took over the leadership,
we asked the people that were there,
here, and
incoming, if five years from now,
when you graduate, what
will pride have done for
it to be memorable in your experience?
And then we executed off that, and much
of that was social, much of that was in
support, some of it was educational,
so, it'll change a bit year to year.
I think what for me has been really
important has been like an emphasis on
building a community, whatever that means.
I feel really connected
to the LGBT people.
I think particularly in my year.
But really at the GSB-
>> Also in your third year.
[LAUGH] [CROSSTALK] All right,
whoa, time really does fly.
I think we're almost out of time but
before we go when Marcela, any final words
of advice for folks that are thinking
about applying to the Standford MBA?
Especially if they're part
of the LGBT community?
>> I'll just shoot a couple out there.
Reach out to co workers if you
know someone who is LGBT and
has a kind of business school they
can be great sources of wisdom.
More generally,
just really take the time to enjoy
the process of writing your essay.
I think part of the decision to come
here was that I had to think so
hard about it, but at the end I really
felt like I know myself better.
So it can be hard but really enjoy,
talk to other people about it,
take the opportunity to get
to know yourself better.
And yeah, help you enjoy it.
>> Thanks Marcela
>> I really agree with that
>> I think one thing I want to flag and
I know we're not talking
about financial aid, but
there are specific LGBT scholarships that
are not necessarily specific to Stanford.
But knowing about the point foundation,
for me was really helpful.
And then there also is LGBT
specific money at Stanford,
so if you're able to be
out I think that that's,
I just wish that had been flagged for
me and the second thing is is
I love talking to potential applicants
about what you're thinking about.
So, kind of following on your advice about
is there's someone that you can reach out
to and ask a little bit to get even
more of a peak into their experience and
to follow up with more questions
I think that I definitely
recommend
>> Doing anything you can
to have those conversations as you're
going through the application process.
>> Yeah, I think my quick tidbit is
just to be authentic to your identity.
For me, like I said, my professional
interest is in the LGBTQ community, so
of course that's going to show up at
length in my application, of course that's
going to show up at length in my essays,
but may or may not be the case for
you depending on how you want to live and
express that identity and your values.
So put down what makes sense for you.
There isn't a magic formula
with your identity nor
with anything else in the application
I really think it is very holistic.
So on that note, well,
thank you both of you for joining us.
>> Thank you.
And also
>> [LAUGH]
>> everyone in the audience for
participating.
I think we are all here because we love
the school, and we love our community, and
we would be super excited to see some of
you all apply and ultimately come here.
You can learn more about the MBA
program on the GSB website,
so
>> The application for
the class starting in the fall of 2017
is going to be available in June.
So, 2017 starting then application
will be available in June.
And if you have questions
about the NBA program
You can continue to submit
them in the chat box.
And there will be staff from the MBA
admissions office that are going
to answer them for
about the next 15 fifteen minutes.
But, that's it for us, so
thanks again and have a great day.
>> Thank you.